so I'm going to talk about
hidden owners
shining a light on UK corpora
so this is using public data this is
actually nothing to do with my day job
this is me doing charity data science
work I'm gonna try and hit on a number
of things in the course of the talk I'm
gonna try and give you the idea behind
it I'm going to try and encourage you to
engage with charitable works I'm going
to if anybody's who hears every use
neo4j I'm going to give a very a bit of
a little demo intro so that if you've
never used it you can see how you could
get started on it but do not expect the
need to see anything advanced and then
I'm going to get through some of the
actual outcomes of the projects and some
of the lessons learned you've kind of
had a quick intro to me I am currently a
senior data scientist at hal 24k we're
building smart city solutions i'm also
volunteer an ambassador and currently
committee member for data kind which is
the charity that links to this project
i'm now also a Royal Society
entrepreneur residents so I I'm I'm
meant to be trying to bring best
practice from data science industry back
into academic environments if anybody's
got any actual good ideas on how to do
that I managed to blog it so they've
given me the position for the next two
years but we'll see what I come up with
and then just me in my musings there's
my twitter handle my linkedin halls for
the pointy hat comm is a very very badly
written blog because i haven't written
anything for about seven months so i
need to start doing stuff again and in
part actually at times nicely with this
is when i got linked into this project
so the results you're about to hear
about are from collaboration between
data kind and an NGO called Global
Witness who he has heard of data kind
great who he is volunteered with data
kind that is not so good so for those of
you who don't know data kind is a
charity that well I'll get shot if I say
we're a matchmaking service between data
scientists
because we do a lot more than that the
idea is really to try and get the tech
sector to do pro bono work like the
legal sector traditionally kind of has
so the idea is to find deserving causes
that can make our societies and world's
a better place who generally can't
afford data scientists or don't know
whether they can or whether they should
and so they join together with data kind
to do different projects on a variety of
different scales you can hit me up
afterwards if you want to hear more
details about that but those who saw my
lightning to talk on data kind stuff
last year at last year's my data a
couple of people good that means that I
won't be going over too much familiar
ground we did a dive originated all
weekend hackathon that was on a snapshot
of data that was so successful that we
ended up doing a full seven eight month
project which is what you're about to
hear about so this is a real deep drill
down a team of five of us worked with
the charities to try and build a tool
that wouldn't would help them out so
it's these things are called data call
projects in case it's an internet so
what we wanted to do was the UK is
actually a world leader in corporate
transparency if you can believe it to
some degree they are the first country
in the world to require companies when
they do their filings to report who
controls them now the only way you can
report another company is controlling
you now is if that company is also
registered in the UK because they have
to report who controls them and so the
idea is that ultimately it will always
end in people and so there is no hiding
behind shell corporations you will be
able to get to the bottom of who is
actually controlling the interests and
operating the companies so the UK is the
first country to actually do this and
this is is why it's also so new the
goals of the plot over the project was
we wanted to demonstrate the value and
use of a usability of this data because
there are other countries who say oh we
can't do this because it would be
impossible to do anything with it and
nobody would report things
and and so they were there's an issue of
how well as this worked companies house
also when initially you approached by
they said our data is perfect yeah it's
not so we were gonna we expected to
uncover problems with the data and we
did we also then wanted to actually
start looking at what corporate control
looked like and actually start linking
into data science methodologies to help
as we already heard yesterday in a
similar talk in the keynote if you were
there investigative journalism actually
using these tools these transparencies
these public open releases of data to
actually drive social change through the
media and through investigative
journalism so how are we gonna do this
well we need data I've already said so
the majority the data comes out
companies house the techniques we're
going to apply I've already mentioned
neo we're going to graph all of the data
and this is fundamentally the the the
key tools that we ended up actually
linking everything together whilst we
were working on this project
neo was going to be basically the
backend that's what was gonna host and
run and serve all of the day all of the
data once we constructed our graph this
is PI data so need to make sure I used
Python somewhere in this Python is
actually my tool of choice so that's
kind of where I ended up connecting to
the database and actually cleaning and
processing the data and pushing things
through we were also using notebooks one
of our team one sole member of our team
was an our user and he did some great
work but yes I'm not that hot on my are
maybe I need to get a bit better but we
were sharing ideas and doing some the
exploring exploration all of it was
hosted on AWS with data kind servers and
pandas because these were big tables of
stuff start to getting used quite
heavily for doing certain things
although after yesterday's talk I'm
starting to realize why some of its as
slow as it is because I'm not using
pandas properly or pandas is not
designed to do the things that I was
doing so one of the other things I've
said companies house is the data source
fortunately a number of the things you
can actually get as massive big data
files it depends on whether you like
that or not you can actually download a
list of all active
companies in the UK and I think they
update it monthly and it is about 4.6
million companies so that is when
decompressed a three gigabyte CSV file
so you can start to see why when I first
loaded it all into pandas in one go on
my eight gig laptop it started running
slow some things this isn't so well I
think there are some things that they
can charge if that I mean there are
old-school stuff I remember seeing where
you want this on a DVD posted you they
start charging you money there's there
are a number this is kind of as you can
see I think if there's a beta written at
the top of here a number of these things
are now fully open so the beneficial
open ownership data is also available as
a great big giant data dump if you start
wanting to get deeper which we did which
is why we partnered with some other
organizations because they've done stuff
you can get things like the company
officers and directors but that's only
available by the API and that is rate
limited so you're actually then gonna
you need to either be doing this long
term to pull it all down and to maintain
it all you need to negotiate with them
in which case they may start charging if
you need to do something really clever
like I say we had we partnered in part
with a few other people who already had
built some of these data collections
which made it easier for us to just get
in and start exploring but I wanted to
make a point in the API because you can
actually get all of the data from the
API but then you're on the right limit
so it's sensible to find the ones where
you can get the big data files just
download it within a couple of minutes
and only go to the API when you need the
specifics so how are we going to do this
so this this was for my sins my master
plan I'm now trying to allude to the
Marvel University to obfuscate and not
you know try and claim there's any dodgy
dealings going on anywhere I should give
a very good keynote anything you see
today is not claiming any impropriety in
anything because I haven't done any of
the investigative journalism that's not
my role so whilst things are like oh
that's interesting that should be
followed up nothing you see which is why
you generally will not see any real
names or anything up there is
anyway in the indicative of things being
illegal fraudulent or anything telling
you that now so I can't get sued I am
NOT saying that that is not implied so
in this case what we're doing is we're
create so each colored circle isn't
going to be a node in the database so we
have nodes and we have then
relationships all edges now if you want
to call them and they are labeled so we
have in the sort of pinky orange color
we have the people and we have Jay jonah
Jameson who controls the Daily Bugle in
New York City companies are now in blue
and companies can also control companies
as I said you know this is possible so
actually there's a parent company I've
created now called the Daily Bugle which
owns the New York branch it's also
controlled by somebody called Jay
Jameson and we'll see this as we go
through we now have a problem because
how do we know that these are the same
person might be a problem we'll see and
these companies are registered in the UK
now anybody who knows anything about
spider-man in the Marvel Universe knows
that Norman Osborn also the Green Goblin
is not a nice person and in this case
I've got a made him resident of the
British Virgin Islands where he's
probably avoiding paying his taxes
properly he controls a company called
Oscorp at Oscorp actually has control of
the Daily Bugle so if you're following
the money is it that actually all the
money's being funneled out and then it's
because it's registered out in the
Cayman Islands as well that actually
we're avoiding you know we've heard a
lot from about tax avoidance and you
know money being filtered through
inappropriate places and that's part of
the point here I didn't really mention
what Global Witness did as an NGO they
are generally looking for where people
and resources around the world are being
exploited and their history of figuring
that out is about following the money
and so what this is why they wanted to
investigate transparency and things like
this that you can actually start to see
where people are abusing power or are
not playing by the rules and so on so
forth so this is the concept now spoiler
alert that's what actually my graph
database ends up looking like
unsurprisingly it looks like I designed
it but nicely you can kind of see that
it's doing the same thing so we have
created people we've created companies
they can be linked by controlling
relationships companies can control
companies we've also linked in where
they're registered where their post
codes are what countries they're also
registered in what countries people are
citizens of we also then have sort of
other nodes that are holding their
control kind this allows us to more
easily jump in because the power of the
graph database is that it is if you've
indexed on it it's cheap to find your
starting nodes and then you don't you
can just walk the graph to look for the
patterns you want so if you can find
those key nodes then you've got your
starting points and then you can
navigate around to find the pattern that
you want now for those who've never this
is gonna be interesting to see how this
works
never use neo and would like to play
with it and would like to experiment
with it I would say it's a the community
edition is free I have never paid for
neo4j which I'm sure mark up in the
corner is a little bit disappointed
about I've only used it for side fun
projects and for charity work and so on
so forth if you're not looking for a
full enterprise scaled sharded doing the
really clever stuff and you're just
playing with relatively small growths I
mean I say relatively small this graph
is about 60 gig when it finally gets
built then the community edition is a
great place to get in and play with
stuff and one of the things that I love
they created the other year and we're
gonna see if this actually oh here we go
they created a sandbox they created a
place where you can go and spin up a
nearfall je server and I'm actually
gonna show you exactly how to do it so
you just search from the neo4j sandbox
you'll get there pretty quick shop here
you go I'm gonna log in I've already got
an account so I'm gonna use my github ID
credentials let's get me in and oh great
I can come in get knows who I am they
actually have a load pre-populated so
you can get pre-built datasets what you
saw there was me creating a blank one
and you'll see it takes takes a minute
oh no it's it's coming up
and by default this lasts for three days
and then it will just shut itself down
and delete itself so you don't even have
to worry about maintaining it second now
which is ironic you know I'm waiting I
had control of the video I could have
cut this down but I thought I'd give you
a realistic timescale and here we go
there you go it started and the tabs
then give you when I click on that one
there's the connection details that's
how to go and link in and then once it's
built it'll actually give you some
reason the data model and code and other
things and you can share that even with
other people so that you can
collectively work on things so let's
build a graph so like I say very quick
intro there's a native bolt driver which
will allow you to connect from Python
maintained by the lovely people at near
4j so you don't have there are other
third-party tools like pi tunia which
you can use I actually like to just get
in and just use use there or a driver
because it's it's really faster to read
efficient use that put in some
credentials those are actually the ones
of this little three day demo that's up
on the server so you could connect if
you really want to right now you
probably don't and what I'm gonna do is
I'm going to create a a node here
well a path and what it's gonna do is
it's going to create a person it's going
to connect them this is actually from
the near 4j website may guess works at
neo4j so there's this other person over
here and so you actually suddenly you
get that
and then there's an example that I clean
everything back at at the end I had
hoped I wasn't good enough in doing this
I had hoped to have like a nice mini
full-on demo tutorial that would go with
this that you could all go away and you
can build your own mini snapshot of the
pse data not giving you all three mil or
four 4.6 million companies a smaller
more manageable set and then you could
play with this this notebook which does
this little demo and the next demo
exists on github at that link and I
promise if this video gets to more than
eight hundred
on the channel because that's more than
emmalin currently has from his video
from last year I will guarantee that I
will finish that tutorial no plug there
whatsoever so that's all great in the
context of our graph as I said one of
the important things is being able to
actually find the starting nodes and
actually putting some restrict
restraints on it so this one is in there
as an example that I'm going to make
sure that companies are all unique so I
don't double up on companies the same
for people and postcodes by making them
unique I'm also kind of indexing on them
at the same time do not index on
everything it's something again I've
learned from going to neo4j meetups that
that's a bad idea think about how you're
intending to query it this is basically
us how we locked it down of what we knew
we needed it to work on and then this is
a little example as you saw we need to
be able to connect to countries because
this is kind of an important thing if
you're starting to look for is there
something maybe suspicious happening
because there are certain known
countries in the world which are not the
ones that we're most friendly with or
aren't the most restrictive in their tax
declaration rules or so on and so forth
and so that was an important one we
actually built this effectively using
the iso country codes i built my own
json file of it and then i started
mapping the way that the data is
structured over hence why you I tried to
keep the I think I kept the French name
as well as the English name in case it
came up in places that one also up there
so you can actually see that the data
files are even there so you can actually
create all the countries in the world in
your little graph database it will then
not connect to anything cuz I haven't
done any of the other stuff yet this is
where it gets complicated though because
this for example is the snap a snapshot
of a load of the fields that come out of
your active company register so what you
actually have here are lots of details
which is great you've got company name
company number you've got the registered
address components you have country of
origin you've got company status you've
got
it's been dissolved so on and so forth
now the thing you have to think about is
which features here are effectively
going to be values that you are going to
store as properties on your nodes and
which ones are actually relationships
because you actually want to be able to
navigate and work through that and
siezed equivalents connections between
data because that's where the power of
coming from graphs is you don't want it
in a great big table you want to see the
connection between things and that's why
we were doing this because these are
huge tables and some of the stuff that
you see later on get there you know it
it will be very difficult to do this
many joins on that on tables like that
to try hunting down patterns that you
don't quite know where they're going to
end that you can't read and I've kind of
done it like that because that is the
level now of code to create the country
nodes and to build the relationships
between the sorry not the country the
company nodes to build them and then to
connect them to people and that might be
listed and to the countries where
they're registered and so on and so
forth and you can see that it's a bigger
chunk of code than you saw on the other
little sample notebook it requires a bit
more thought the key thing you're coming
in here is actually there are four
things happening you're building the
company first of all as a single node
and then I'm lik taking the company and
then I'm mapping it to other countries
that it's registered and so then I'm
building the relationship set up there
then I'm looking at okay well actually
where is it found it so there's a has
origin feature so again I can connect it
possibly to another country and then
I've got the postcode when it comes to
actually doing the people that then gets
a little bit more complicated because
then you're looking at even more places
where you can connect things happen so
that's about half way through so that's
not bad that's kind of the how and the
why I'm a former astronomer so there's
my chance of getting an astronomer
photographing how have we actually had
impact what has this done because it's
all well and good building a great big
database of stuff but if you don't use
it what can you do so the first one of
the things you can do is you can find
our PI data colleagues one of them is
SATs
the second row at the front this is
emmalin's corporate ownership network
he's boring so this is emmalin he
controls can't read it on there yet open
vivo limited he is also an officer of
open fever limited so one of the things
I mentioned was we had the officer data
I think there's like 40 million officers
and directors so that is a huge data set
again to play with it's good fun
it's registered at this post code
registered in this country yeah you're
an individual you're a person you're not
a company or a charity I'm afraid to
tell you
and then this pup one over there the
reason why there's no number on that is
actually emmalin is also an officer of a
dissolved company so in my active
company's list I never saw it hence why
I don't have any details about it now if
I was kind of interested the point being
is I can still go back in to the
company's house data and I can start
looking this stuff up because I have a
starting point so nice little simple
beginning point
nothing contentious there either that or
he's very good at hiding what should be
contentious what because you've been
trying to obfuscate what you do or
because you don't do anything okay okay
okay so what else can we do I now to be
honest you could you could do this just
by loading the data in the point being
is that you can do stuff that you were
doing a tabular analysis or you would do
just through a normal thing of but you
can also effectively pull this start
pulling this out back out at the graph
for every person in the graph we created
their data but the date of birth was
part of the record at least their month
and year so we can come up with an age
and apparently four thousand toddlers
are in charge of British companies now I
know there are some adult toddlers in
charge of companies that we've all
encountered however there are actually
four thousand beneficial owners under
the age of two now there is a concept
that actually that might be legit you
know maybe they do own more than 20
five percent of the shares in a company
that they've done been done but I hope
they're not actually executing any kind
of control over those companies all all
there's possible issues interestingly
and this kind of goes back to the data
cleanliness comment that I initially
made one of them hasn't been born yet
one of them is actually born in 2021 and
this is one of the points of feedback
that we actually we have very quickly
taken back to Companies House Companies
House does not require you when you
register a company to provide any
identification
there is no identity check there is no
nothing and most of what you put in has
historically been a free text box so you
can make mistakes maybe you make
mistakes on purpose who knows the
problem is it's very difficult to audit
these things at that point one of the I
said we know we put nationality and
citizenship in to the graphs I've seen
somebody declare themselves as British
with two T's I've seen some ones that
clear themselves Cornish I hadn't
realized this assistant they'd seceded
from the King the United Kingdom and
actually that has gone back to Companies
House they are MIT I believe they have
actually now changed that to no longer
be a drop-down box you have to choose
from an allowed set of countries now
we're all aware that these things have
challenges on the other way if you're
too prescriptive and you haven't thought
of all the options you now cause
problems in your registration but
leaving pure free text boxes when you're
not doing any validation of who people
are in the context of transparency
doesn't help you that much trying to
figure out who people are and if they're
the same person if you know there is
more than one Emily and clay in the
country there is fortunately there isn't
another Emmeline Robert clay answer you
had your own unique thing and assuming
that the other one isn't you so what
other cool stuff did we find so one of
the things that we went looking for is
okay
so based upon these rules of reporting
true controls you there it's meant to
end
at somebody all people they should not
be cyclical all of those are cyclical in
fact you've got I mean this that I mean
he's brilliant I mean this one controls
this one that controls this one that
controls this one that controls this one
so you know whose fault is something who
is to blame who is responsible and now
if there are a number of them which you
will see from these little ones down
here that look almost like Christmas
baubles those are people claiming that
their company controls their company and
what we probably expect is these are
self-employed people who didn't
understand what they were registering
how to do the register so interesting
that has impact that we've taken back to
Companies House of you might want to
educate people better in what are you
trying what you meant to be putting here
however the company that registered
company one controls company - the
controls company 3 that controls company
for the controls company 1 when they
literally use company name one company
name two company name three company name
four I think they're trying they're kind
of they're definitely know what they're
doing and they're not doing what they're
meant to do we actually found things
like that you know nobody they're not
even trying to hide it because they know
nobody's looking or nobody has been
looking and so this is starting to now
feed into companies house actually doing
some investigations as well as there's
some investigative journalism I can't
give you a lot of the juicy stuff
because we literally only finished the
project like a month ago and if you're
gonna do data journalism the journalists
like to get the headline not me at a
conference
surrounded by load of Python geeks so I
yeah you'll get something so you can
start to find all sorts of patterns you
can find chains and like I said there is
nothing wrong with this there are some
for example this one over here on the
right I think is there is no person in
charge of this network and that's fine
this is actually something like racket
benek so so huge giant publicly public
the tradable pharmaceutical so no bee
owns more than 25% of the stock so there
is no single controller and so therefore
actually that's completely legitimate
but the fact that you can get in and
start finding these things is a hell a
lot more powerful than the classic ways
you just would be finding one piece of
paper all right they're controlled by
this person over here and someone else
in you're trying you know the level of
complexity comes out of the graph easily
it would not come out the flat database
table in any way shape or form as easily
as it does here this was a fun one like
I said we map postcodes so there are a
couple of postcodes in London that have
like 20,000 companies registered to them
that seems a bit odd like I said it
might be fine it might be legit but you
won't know until you look and the idea
is this is the sort of thing that again
comes out easily from the graph they may
well do exactly that's the point is
there is nothing illegal about this but
there may be places that aren't entirely
that they know maybe they are a company
farm yes they just produce these things
but maybe they get connected to other
things if you found a law firm that was
doing building shell companies for
someone you might want to be
investigating that law firm so the point
being is that it comes out really easily
and so this is then just in the exact I
actually had to cut down I couldn't do
that I couldn't render that many nodes
without breaking my browser so that's
why you just have little mirrors over on
the other side you just suddenly can see
these massive concentrations in certain
places and they may be if you know
something if you know other information
do this in a very Bayesian way combine
that with something else and suddenly
you have journalistic lead problems and
things to improve this graph which you
can't read on the left is Donald Trump
in the UK and this illustrates again the
point with data cleanliness these four
nodes green nodes over here are Donald
Trump Donald J Trump Trump Donald John
Trump because again you might choose to
put your middle name in you might just
put in initial in and so those I have to
we had to manually create our own unique
identifiers for people and you can't do
it to call
first and last name otherwise the number
of John Smith's being mapped to being
the same person will be horrific and
equally if you do it at the level that
we've done it at I mean it's not too bad
they do still connect but we know that
this is something to be improved so we
will we didn't get to this point but we
have so anything well I can levenshtein
distance the unique identifier I've made
and I can look for how close they are
connected via companies and controlling
relationships in the graph and maybe
that would point to me too
those look like they might be the same
people and then you might be able to
reactivate but like I say it's it's kind
of just an interesting thing in it and
it's a point that came out of stuff that
we could feedback impact we started the
impact it has been happening there is
data to there's a lovely piece on file
on four that went out in January or
February online I would highly encourage
you to go and watch 11th of February
2018 Potters Bar you creighton stolen
billions so the former Ukrainian
president basically managed to swindle a
load of money get a load of money out of
the country went through the UK they
went through a number of corporate
entities in the UK and some of our
analysis for them was linking back not
directly on the case but is a reflection
of points of view it's a nice piece in
in The Guardian this is an interesting
case actually I would highly encourage
you to read it recently be the
government in the last 12-18 months
trumpeted prosecuting someone for fraud
gently creating companies in the UK
except that person was doing it and
creating companies with MPs as kin as
owners of those companies without them
knowing and then telling them about it
and pointing out the problems with how
you can register a company without
having to be validated and then he
immediately shut the company down but
then the government chose to prosecute
him for illustrating the problem and the
ease of fraud he well the problem was he
self documented everything really well
and then went yeah here you go here's
the evidence they went ok good yeah you
broke the look I've been told actually
that because he pled guilty he had to
pay me the government
costs he had to pay a fine Singh like 24
25 thousand pounds I believe it's been
crowdfunded that the Chibs you've gone
with you know what he's not paying that
I hope it's been raised I need to
looking at myself I only heard about
this case actually recently and keep an
eye out in the Financial Times tomorrow
apparently we have something that again
has been built off of this I'm finding
out about it as quickly as you the so
some of the key early findings that
we've got is that so there are four
point 1 million companies now on the
beneficial ownership register 3.7
million of them have have actually
declared at least one beneficial owner
so compliance when it's been argued you
can't do this easily isn't that hard and
has been achieved you've already heard
about the ones under the age of two
there's an issue of Scottish limited
partnerships where they tend to have a
lot of them are connected to former
Soviet countries which is in is a much
higher fraction of than limited
companies and apparently this is again a
thing that a number of journalists have
been using looking at Scottish limited
partnerships and their own rules as to
maybe we should investigate here a
little bit more 5 beneficial owners
forget just the the postcode masts
things 5 beneficial owners control more
than 6,000 companies again there's
nothing inherently wrong with it but it
might be something that people want to
look at so we have ongoing discussions
with Companies House we have been
lobbying other governments to adopt open
registries they've actually some of them
have been coming to coming to the
charity there is going to be a white
paper a report out from Global Witness
which were actually summarized out of
this it was meant to be out by today
which is what I was hoping I was gonna
get all the juicy stuff but it's been
delayed because actually there's so much
interest from journalists they've been
doing the journalism so like I say there
are things coming out keep an eye out
some of it might be us have a check out
of the the blog post and there's that
the link to that Guardian article like I
said I'd highly recommend those ones
there's always more to be done but there
are no secrets to success quoting Colin
Powell as a result of preparation hard
work and learning from failure yes we
made lots of mistakes as we did this but
we're also pointing out the errors in
some the other systems and hopefully
it'll
works to make everything a lot better
and the obligatory self lied whilst this
has nothing to do with my day job we are
hiring if you look in the the jobs
channel on slack you'll see that there's
a DevOps data engineer based in
Amsterdam if you want to hear more about
the company that I work for my day job
come and find me if you want to hear
more about volunteering and offering
your services today to kind either go
there and register and we'll start
bombarding you with emails or invite you
in for an interview if you want to
already just get the jump on to a
project or you can talk to me and
finally thank you all thanks for the
interesting dog any plans to link this
with Panama papers you know there's a
lot of so one of the interesting things
is the sandbox environment that I demoed
you can spin up the Panama papers data
set in there
and I believe somebody from the charity
actually did that they span up the
sandbox and they tried to connect it
back to our neo4j database to map stuff
across I didn't go into all of the stuff
that we had because you don't want to
get into all of it find you till things
like the countries we've done things
like we've mapped financial secrecy
wreck audits that have been done on them
so that you can find which are the dodge
Logie come countries maybe we've also I
believe gone and looked at registered
politicians around Europe so you can
actually map their identities in start
trying to find the the beautiful thing I
loved about this project is that whilst
to a degree it wasn't you know it was a
lot of data engineering I'm a data
scientist my normal day job I normally
am doing the really cool stuff at the
other end some would argue but I like to
dabble it enables so much more this is a
great foundational piece that can be
scale and it's the other thing I like
about graph database systems is that
enriching it with more data isn't that
hard it's you just go in and you start
linking it to the other things so yeah
the idea of using the Panama and the
paradise paper releases I know that some
of the journalists certainly are oh how
can we do more about more with this and
connecting
this one more question so there is a
global legal entity ID right for
companies across is that thank you I
could imagine that time can play a big
role here and in particular how sort of
relationship I develop over time imagine
for example and I don't know they as a
country from my court where the company
is based obviously last 200 years I
might just change and I was wondering
your ideas for what you think about how
this is going you know it's an
interesting component because we're well
aware because like I said the you get
effectively the registers get updated
monthly at the moment the plan is just
that so you can rebuild this quite
quickly we've written scripts to to just
generate it so it is a static it's not
trying to map changes over time mainly
low-hanging no there's plenty of work to
be done just with the static snapshot
but it's definitely I think we've
considered that actually you might want
to take it to another level that you
actually track the changes that this
person is no longer a director they've
been dissolved off here I mean one of
the one of the data sets is those who
are not allowed to be directors and
officers of companies anymore so finding
them all finding out all they're no
longer the director but their secretary
got promoted to being director after
they quit kind of start to again look
like there's something not quite right
going on there so a time dimension would
be very interesting neo is not the best
suited full-time I mean there is no date
stamp datatype as far as I know still so
it's there are some tricks that you need
to to play with to do that but it's like
I say it's something interesting it'll
be great to invest time in it
so this problem that you're solving is
one that a lot of auditors face I mean
effectively if you're auditing a company
identifying the relationships between
all of the directors and suppliers and
so on is an issue you're doing any work
with the accountancy sector in general
we haven't because like I say this has
been done purely between a non-profit
and a charity group offering data
science skills
so we haven't gone that we I think we
may have approached somebody all do you
want to have you got any team members
you'd like to volunteer their time in I
think they were too busy doing their own
auditing so yeah we haven't haven't
looked at that but you're quite right
and I mean it's one of the things that
comes out of the Guardian articles as
its pointed out that companies that are
responsible for creating companies
actually have to meet certain
requirements Companies House doesn't you
go into creating your company you know
online like I say there's no identity
check there's no validation done there
yet if you're a private entity doing it
you would be expected to do these things
and so there's kind of a two-tier system
almost in operation so ya know if like
I'm sure there are are that you know
maybe they're more advanced the nice
thing about this is because the data
only started becoming available in 2016
so a full the first full year of data
was only available like July August 2017
and we started this project last year
you mentioned lobbying with other
countries the question is how likely you
see something like Companies House in
other EU countries and how possible
would be EU regulations my understanding
is that there are there isn't there
isn't there is significant progress with
other EU countries about this concept
I'm not involved so I've been told by by
global witnesses that's where they've
been doing some of their lobbying and
their work and that there is definitely
momentum building that stuff is going to
happen quite in what form and whether
it's a central required regulation comes
in rather than in I think at the moment
it's individual countries choosing to do
it rather than anybody requiring this
level of transparency in you know
initiative data
[Applause]